hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll a
little while back I was at a cosmology
conference and there was a talk being
given by Jim Peebles Jim Peebles will be
very well known to anyone who knows
about cosmology he's a professor at
Princeton one of the Grand Old Men of
cosmology he was a young physicist
working with Robert dicki in the 1960s
when they predicted and tried to observe
the cosmic microwave background before
being scooped by penus and Wilson so
he's been around he's seen everything
and he's a super nice guy so everyone
wants to hear what Jim pebles has to say
so he was talking to this group about
the acceleration of the universe and he
showed a picture of the people who
discovered the acceleration of the
universe that's Saul peroor Adam Reese
former mindscape guest and current
colleague of mine at Johns Hopkins and
Brian Schmidt their teams of course also
had a lot to do with it I want to give
them all the credit but these are the
folks folks who were on stage at a
ceremony in Japan with some officials
from the Japanese government why am I
telling you this because uh Jim bble
said this very amusing thing he sort of
looked at the picture and paused and he
said you notice how the scientists the
astronomers are very well-dressed it was
you know an off official event everyone
dressed their best and he says they're
in their suits but the suits are kind of
clearly off the rack they're they fit
okay but they're not perfect whereas the
politicians he said the Japanese
politicians have these perfectly
tailored bespoke suits and you can
actually just tell that they're made to
fit these people specifically and the
audience loved this it was hilarious it
was all done in very good spirits he
wasn't insulting anyone or anything like
that he was just making a Ry observation
and it was funny because it was
different it was not what you expect we
don't usually talk about the fashion
choices of science scientists thank
goodness there's literally a website or
there used to be anyway called Prof or
hobo where you're supposed to guess
whether the picture is of a professor
often a scientist or just a person a
hobo right in other words scientists
don't put a lot of effort into dressing
well but I think that there's something
to be said for dressing well or at least
dressing intentionally and thoughtfully
you know when it comes to science and
philosophy I often say that scientists
can't choose to not do philosophy but
they can do it badly if they don't want
to pay attention to it scientists are
always talking about the nature of
science and stuff like that which is
really just kind of cheap not thoughtful
philosophy and I think the same thing
goes true for wearing clothes if you
wear clothes you can do it thoughtfully
or not thoughtfully and you know what
it's completely fine in the case of
wearing clothes to do it not very
thoughtfully just wear whatever you want
that's fine but you are making a choice
about what to wear even if your choice
is whatever is in front of me I'm going
to wear that so there is a question a
set of questions to be asked about what
are we conveying what are the choices
that we're making what are the
statements we're giving to the World by
how we dress and how can we do it well
how can we make the kind of statement
that we want to make I cannot think of
any better person to talk to about these
issues and today's guest Derek guy many
of you who go on Twitter these days will
know that Derek has become a mini
celebrity on Twitter over the past year
uh he is one of the people whose Twitter
accounts were
inexplicably sent you know
algorithmically boosted to a whole bunch
of people the good news is his Twitter
account is great so no one really
complains unless they just uh want to
complain about it because Derek not only
knows a great deal about clothes and how
to wear them but also thinks about it
that's why he's a good good mindscape
guest this episode is not going to be
mostly fashion tips okay there might be
a fashion tip that sneaks in here or
there but it's mostly going to be
thinking about what it means to wear a
clothes what you are saying like we said
what is the cultural situation into
which your choices of what to wear fall
so and he's very very good at that it's
clear from the Twitter thread that he is
being prescriptive and and that he says
you know I think this works this doesn't
but but at the end of the day you got to
wear what you got to wear you should
just understand what it means to be
wearing those things so to me that is a
very mindscape attitude and a little bit
of a departure for us but that's okay
departures are what we're all about so
let's
[Music]
go
Derek guy welcome to the mindscape
podcast thank you for having me I think
that it seems as if we're in a somewhat
weird cultural moment as as it refers to
clothing and fashion I mean on the one
hand we have the media we have social
media as well as mainstream media
flooding us with image of celebrities
dressing in different ways you know I
can't watch an NBA game without seeing
pictures of the players arriving in
their fits and being judged on them but
at the same time we're dressing very
casually or even thoughtlessly ourselves
when we go into work these days how do
you feel about what it means to be
someone thinking about fashion and
clothing in this particular moment well
I think the reason
why I mean to be sure I just to put it
out there I I only really think about
men's clothing and I write about men's
clothing I don't um my my Niche is not
in women's clothing but certainly women
have been thinking about clothing um for
a lot longer than men and I think it's
just two things have happened in the
last 20 to 25 years that has increased
male interest in clothing one is that
there's just um although I I think it's
still there um fashion has always been
coded as uh for for a long time fashion
has been coded as a feminine frivolous
interest so men um uh you know when you
go back into
you know go back in history you see the
king of France wearing all these like
crazy like you know gowns and and men
used to wear red heels and all of these
kind of like resplendant you know like
textures and and materials and then
there was something called the Great
renunciation where men gave up those
things and went for much more auster
clothing and left fashion to women and
that uh was reinforced during the Oscar
wild trials um where many of our
stereotypes of gay men came from that
trial the kind of affet uh interested in
art and clothes and witty kind of
stereotype of a gay man and then for
much of the 20th century because of the
combination of the great male
renunciation of men leaving clothes to
to women and also the stereotypes that
if you were interested in clothing
people would suspect that you may be a
gay man and for much of that period that
also meant that you were considered less
masculine um that made up the bulk of
the 20th century even even though there
were many you know parts of the 20th
century where men expressed great
interest in clothes for example um you
know in London during the 60s there was
like this peacock Revolution where you
know men would wear these really Dandy
outfits but for the most part that
characterizes much of 20th century dress
in Western society and I think that
started to break down um at the turn of
the 21st
century when those gender Norms start
breaking down a little bit more and
they've kind of gone almost into hyper
drive now even though I still think
there is a lot of taboo for men to be
interested in clothes the taboo is less
strong now than it was let's say in the
1950s um so that has allowed men to feel
more comfortable being interested in
this subject whereas 75 years ago they
they might you know they might not want
to Signal too strong of an interest in
close because they thought it might
signal something about them that they
didn't want to signal so that's one one
part just generational changes in how we
think of um uh quote unquote proper
gender Behavior and the other part is I
think we
live we are seeing more
nowadays um the internet has put many
people in front of a wider audience even
if you have like an Instagram account um
whereas before if you
weree you know I mean you you could go
through much of life not thinking about
clothes because you were seen by a
smaller number of people and if you wore
something silly like most people would
forget it about it after a while whereas
now there's like a record of how you
look over the course of many years
because many people are documenting
themselves online and it's seen even if
even if your Instagram account may not
actually get that much traffic the
potential of these photos circulating
puts a greater um incentive to pay a
little bit more attention to your addess
than you may have in you know the the
90s for example so I think the internet
and the the breakdown of gender Norms um
or or normative gender Behavior has has
contributed to this kind of boost in in
male interest and clothing there there
was also a period in the early 2000s
where in in the 90s if you're interested
in I I should I should preface this I
think many people in the 90s and before
were interested in clothing but they
didn't think of their interest as an
interest in clothing so the way I often
frame it is um to give an
example if you grew up in the 80s or 90s
you may have been involved in like a
youth subculture movement you may have
been into you know punk music or
skateboarding or hip-hop or whatever it
is and many people in these communities
have Keen sense of how they're supposed
to dress they know what is like the
right jacket the right shoes but they
don't think of that interest as an
interest in clothing that interest is
primarily linked to some other activity
like skateboarding surfing dancing
whatever it may be and that also
expresses itself in the workplace people
are still keenly aware that there are
certain ways that they should present
themselves but they do not think of that
as an interest in clothing so the people
in the n IES that had an explicit
interest in clothing were like fashion
guys they were interested in helmet
langing and you know Marella and all of
these name brands um again breaking
against that taboo but starting in the
early 2000s there was a narrative kind
of
fomenting
that um an interest in clo could
be um it could be recoded in these kind
of masculine terms so Give an example
like you in the early 2000s there was
this idea of like dressing like a
grown-up or dressing like your
grandfather or investing in Classics um
getting back to Heritage clothing buying
quality clothing all of these things
allowed men to develop an interest in
clothing without Crossing that gender
kind of like taboo of like oh you're a
man interest in clothing it was like no
I'm just dressing for respect or I'm
dressing you know like my grandfather
whatever is there was this narrative
that allowed people to more more easily
get in I think that uh that narrative
has been dead for like about 10 years I
mean nobody really cares about that
narrative anymore um but that allowed a
huge wave of guys 20 years ago to get
into clothing while still Fe feeling you
know heterosexual masculine all these
all these things essentially without
feeling threatened um and then that
group you know made it a little bit more
um okay for other guys to also develop
an interest in clothing um all of these
kind of like cultural moments I think
have led us to this point where you have
more men interest in clothing although I
still think uh there is this
like you know like many people think
that they are smarter or like you know
better than other people because they
are so explicitly like you know like
they care so little about clothing that
they're so much more intellectual than
other people um so yeah I think that's
that's still the dominant narrative but
it it is less so now than it was in
previous decades well this is a great
segue into the whole connection between
clothing and The Wider culture right I
mean you mentioned on your Twitter feed
pretty often the idea of clothing as
cultural language you know when you're
wearing something no matter how generic
or not very fashionable it is you are
fitting in to a wider cultural context
that's not something you can help but do
so I guess the argument could be made
correct me if this is not an argument
you want to make but an argument could
be made that you should at least put
some thought into what are the signals
that you're
sending yeah I I mean one even if you
put no thought into it you're close send
a message anyway so um I've I've I've
always strongly believed that you should
never judge a person's inner qualities
based on their dress but it is an
undeniable fact that other people will
judge you based on your dress and um
that is at least one reason to put a
little bit more thought into your
clothing and then I would say that even
people who claim to not put thought into
the clothing put at least some thought
into their clothing they sometimes guys
tell me well I only dress for Comfort
well it's not purely true because a
skirt may be very comfortable on day but
many men don't wear skirts so they still
put some thought into what is you know
how they how they want to dress to
project certain ideas about themselves
whether that's gender class um cultural
identity you know you may dress to say
I'm an academic or you may dress to say
I'm a smart you know smart person or you
may dress to say I'm a respectable
person you may dress to say I'm you know
you know whatever whatever you could
dress to say I'm I identify as a man
whatever it may be PE these these like
messages are very
um the way we choose clothes to
broadcast those things even for people
who claim to not think about clothing
are so second nature that they don't
even think about how they may be
choosing certain things over other
things um a skirt to me is more
obviously comfortable than jeans but
most guys are going to wear jeans
um just because that's like what guys do
you know how how objective do you think
the standards are I mean do you think
that there at the end of the day are
good and bad ways to dress or is it
relative to something
else I always like in um dress to
language and I I really like using Gom
Chomsky um as I'm sure your listeners
know you know Nome Chomsky the linguist
and also political commentator but in
his linguistic work he's famous for the
phrase colorless green ideas sleep
fiercely as an example of a sentence
that makes grammatical sense but is
semantically nonsensical right has no
meaning and I think that's true also for
clothing
um to break to think of this in terms of
like when when I see people discussing
clothes online often they'll they'll
take these things as like scientific
principles like does black go with blue
or um is this objectively good or bad
and to me that doesn't that's like
asking if a sentence is you know
objectively good or bad sometimes a
sentence is bad because you're not
communicating anything the sentence
doesn't make any sense um sometimes a
sentence can be good just because it
communicates what it's supposed to
communicate sometimes a sentence can be
beautiful and that can be in the eyes of
the beholder but thinking of clothes in
terms of cultural language gets you out
of the Paradigm of believing that
clothes are either purely a subjective
expression or some kind of
objective you know some some there's
some objective measure to
Beauty fashion is different than other
forms of you know visual communication
and that it's the way that we broadcast
our identity and our aspirations and our
even our mood for the day um so I think
when you think of it in terms of
sociological language it makes a lot
more sense there was um
I was thinking of this the other day
there was um I don't know if you're this
this might
strike I I don't know if the audience
listens to rap music but for
example in 2020 the year 2020 there was
a rapper named CJ who came up with a
song called whoopy and it was a huge
summer hit um and the term whoopy came
from the leader of a blood gang in New
York and it was originally a gang call
for for that group the the group on the
street would say whoopy on the street to
identify with each other this rapper who
happens to not be from this gang took
that street slang turned it into a
really catchy song and then all of a
sudden a bunch of other people were
saying whoopty unaware of its
Origins um and I think when you when you
look at the the kind of genetic traces
of language and how language evolves and
how slang you know gets popularized and
who can create slang and who's not
allowed to create
slang it's very easy then to like think
of clothing in that sense somebody who
may hold a lot of cultural capital can
wear something and make it cool like
within a small community some some other
person may take that and then popularize
it to another group and then that group
takes it and they use it in a whole
different way and then all of a sudden
you know the the meaning of that that
either that slang or that garment
changes um and I think that's you know
it's much easier to think of clothing in
terms of language when you see the
evolution of how clothes are used and
how they're worn and how certain Styles
go from being you know in or out um just
in the same way that you know like many
of us don't use you know slang like
tubular anymore right so um it's kind of
like that well and this comes up against
another issue I mean maybe we should be
very basic um for we've already started
the conversation but to just to get some
things on the table here dressing well
in this if I'm following what you're
saying doesn't mean just wearing a suit
or wearing a nice dress if you're a
woman there's all sorts of ways that you
can
dress nicely without dressing you know
expensively or
formally yeah I think
[Music]
um I'm sure your listeners are familiar
with Bordeaux and you know the ideas of
cultural taste and hegemonic taste so
there is there are Notions of good taste
with a capital g capital t and in my
view these are basically the practices
of you know the Elite Class so good
taste is often you know I used to be on
a on a men's wear forum and Michael
Anton who went on to be um an adviser
for Trump he started a thread on this
forum actually and uh Michael happens to
have a lot of Clouts in this kind of
like small menw community um but me
Michael started this thread where he
would give feedback to people and tell
them whether they were dressing in good
taste or bad taste okay and people would
go into this thread eager to get you
know Mike's opinion of like is this good
taste is this you know did I do it right
and if you if you went into the thread
and if you're new to tailor clothing a
lot of it could seem random like why is
this shirt in Good Taste and why is that
shirt in bad taste why is this shoe in
Good Taste why is that shoe in bad taste
and it's much easier to understand if
you understand the notion of good taste
again with capital g capital t in terms
of the social practices of Western
Elites prior to like the 1980s so we're
talking of like you know like British
Aristocrats right Italian
industrialists um the the Kennedy family
like these types of people and when you
understand that their practices which
they every single group has practices
you know like bikers and and
Harley-Davidson clubs have practices it
just so happens that the position of
this group of essentially old money is
coded as good taste because of their
social
status and uh many kind of marxist
cultural commentators have noted that
this this is essentially a way for elite
classes to impose their cultural power
even deeper into the bodies of the
people that they subjugate um but this
notion that their taste is good and
everyone else taste is bad is how we
wind up with again capital g capital t
good taste um so yes I think there is
such a thing as like when you see
something and it conforms to that
specific taste that taste is so
hegemonic that culture that that status
is so well understood that many people
will recognize it as quote unquote good
taste however every single group has
their notion of taste if you go
to um you know if you went to an
underground Punk Club they they have
their Notions of what is a good style
and that is according to their social
group if you go to you know a a biker
event if you go to a low riders Club if
you go anywhere all of these groups have
ways
to regulate group behavior and people
will then dress in ways to both identify
themselves as part of the group but also
to identify themselves as Unique
Individuals IND individuals within that
group so they will conform to the notion
of taste but then often try to do
something different to either impress
their peers or to express themselves as
individuals um so to go back to your
question yes I think there is a notion
of good taste it's sociological it comes
from hegemonic culture and Elite
practices but um there's also a lower
you know lower case G lower case T good
taste which is contextual to the social
practices of any group um and that's
where I think clothing becomes much more
interesting where you recognize these as
um sociological practices and you can go
to like near me there are biker
clubs um and it becomes fascinating like
why do you think this specific genan
jacket is good and that other jean
jacket is bad
um seeing how these groups Express
themselves in terms of clothing I think
is
is a much more interesting way to to
look at clothing than just to think of
you know I don't know um how to addess
you know how to address According to
some objective me measure well the thing
that you just said that I thought was
really interesting was the need for
people in a group to kind of fit in but
also maybe they want to be a little
quirky and individualistic right and but
there's the the next line of that is but
it has to make sense in some way uh I
mean you have a lot of fun on the
Twitter feed with celebrities and and
political figures and and you've poked
gentle fun at Jordan Peterson for
example for apparently wearing suits and
so forth but with just weird things that
make really no sense and maybe the the
message that comes through is it's okay
to be weird but be weird for some
purpose at
least yeah again it's to me it's the
same as as writing I mean there are
poets and and writers who use language
in unconventional ways to express their
own style but that doesn't mean that me
randomly
stringing not even random words but
random letters together like someone can
just look at that that's not the same as
like reading I don't know E Cummings or
something
um you have to form a sentence to
communicate something and you can be
creative with your the way that you
compose that sentence
but it still has to be somewhat
culturally legible I I want to say also
like I I've always strongly you don't
have to have any interest in clothes you
can go through life right and you know
not pay attention to clothes at all and
we thankfully live in a time where there
is less consequence to that now than
there was in previous generations in
previous generations people would gossip
about you you could be sent home from
work for wearing the wrong shirt and you
know all of these like crazy material
repercussions there are especially for
women again I primarily focus on men's
clothing but for men's clothing there's
reasonably less repercussions now than
there were in the past and I think
that's a good thing you can go through
life and not happen to have this as a
hobby but if you are interested in
dressing well I think you'll have more
success if you think of it in terms of
cultural language
versus can I use a neck tie as a belt
you know um
I mean yeah you like technically can but
it it will be weird you know so sure the
one other current news example I wanted
to get on the record was John fedman uh
but we're going to have some listeners
who are not in the United States so they
probably For Better or For Worse have no
idea who we're talking about do you want
to explain who John fedman is and why
he's in uh fashion arguments right
now sure so John fedman is a center from
Pennsylvania uh he and he has caused a
lot of controversy because he rarely
confirms uh conforms to um political
dress codes and so he often walks the
halls of Congress in basketball shorts
and oversized hooded sweatshirts and
sneakers um which in you know that's
just very casual attire
and you know when he first got elected I
I wrote a thread saying that this man
should get custom suits even though
custom suits are thousands of dollars
very expensive um but his suits fit him
so poorly because he's a very large you
know he's very tall he's he's he's very
broad he has a very broad shouldered
kind of build he's not going to fit into
an off the rck suit he's going to he's
not even going to fit into a made to
measure suit he needs a bespoke suit and
that will literally cost him 4,000 at
minimum and I said but he should invest
in that because what ends up happening
is that when he wears these awkward
suits that are so short they show the
lower half of his shin and they the
jacket like lifts off of his neck and I
mean just they're like a mess is that he
ends up causing a lot of discourse
around his clothes and so that
was he's gotten a lot of heat in the US
because um conservatives hate him
because they feel that he uh unjustly
want won his election and he's also been
very outspoken against Donald Trump who
has many frevent supporters so and so
forth so conser have never liked him for
political reasons but they've often
picked on his dress because he doesn't
conform to the Notions of kind of like
respectable
attire but this really came to a head
when Chuck Schumer um changed the Senate
rules to allow Federman into the Senate
chamber without a suit um whereas before
any male entering the Senate chamber
would would have to wear a suit so many
people felt this
was such an affront to the Senate and
like this horrible thing and I happen to
catch a lot of flak on on Twitter um
because I often remark on the attire of
uh politicians and not even just
politicians but also like wealthy
business people and so and so forth I've
refrained from talking about Federman
originally because he was hospitalized
for depression in the same way that I
don't talk about like Mitch mcconell
walks the halls in um dress sneakers and
I never comment on it because he's
suffered multiple Falls and you know
like this there just like kind of I
think a reasonable level of not being a
jerk that you know you just you just
shouldn't do certain things so I've
refrained from commenting on fedman
because he was hosp hospitalized for
depression but when the rule change
happened it became such a controversy of
how can we
allow a man into the chamber wearing
shorts and hoodies um why are we
changing the rules for this one person
you know he's disrespecting the Senate
he's unfit for office so and so forth
and I wrote an oped um saying that I
think Federman should wear a suit simply
because clothing is not important and he
should conform to these simply so that
we talk about more important things
which is
policies however again it's such a
important point in for me that I
strongly believe that you should never
judge a person's inner qualities or the
quality of the work based on their
attire and I am shocked at the number of
people who don't see that as like a
obvious truth because surely they must
have poorly dressed friends people in
their family if you spend any time in
Academia you
know many smart people don't dress well
and that is like I do know that there's
no correlation there's no correlation
between their dress and the quality of
the work if you want to understand the
quality of someone's work read their
paper listen to what they have to say
look at their you know student reviews
whatever it may be that you want to
understand the quality of the work but
their dress is completely unrelated I
don't think you should show up uh you
know in a in a chicken suit just because
then you generate needless conversation
about your chicken suit but if you were
to look at
someone's attire it should not be uh you
should not use that as a proxy for more
important inequalities so I I said that
in a political article and it it got so
much backlash um because uh many people
felt that I was being partisan but also
I think many people do think that it's
an affront to the Senate and I just
think that
this is like pointless kind of like
Victorian Pearl clenching um you know
respect for the Senate is is whether or
not you treat your job seriously and you
can judge that directly by what bills
they sponsor what bills they pass what
deals they make so and so forth you just
look at that um if every single I I
wrote on Twitter if every single
politician went to savaro and bought up
a spok suit and looked beautiful no
American life would would be improved
it'd be like a meaningless gesture um so
that's
my I I have this view that you know
clothing is is uh more important than
what many people think but it's
definitely pretty trivial in in the
grand scheme of things do you know if
fedman has actually come out with a
positive defense of his short and Hoodie
wearing no I have never seen him uh I
reached out to the campaign when I was
writing that political article and I
said I'm writing something about uh
Federman dress and I'd like to you to
answer some of these questions one of
the questions was you know why does he
choose to you know CH choose to not wear
a suit didn't hear back um I don't have
any views I I think that's like his own
the only person that knows the answer to
that is him and his you know the people
closest to him um I I do think that many
people claim that he's doing it to
signal his allegiance to kind of like
blue collar workers and I don't I have a
hard time thinking it's that kind of
like highminded because if it was I
think he'd be more vocal about it um he
may
just the other thing is that I don't
actually know his reasons for not
wearing a suit but I will say I
encounter men who resent wearing suits
all the time so it's not weird to me to
find another person who resents wearing
a suit because especially someone of his
build because they know they look bad in
a suit I mean you don't have to be a
suit expert to look in the mirror and
say this doesn't fit me um and he
probably doesn't want to spend you know
I mean a bespoke suit again is $44,000
right he would need at least five of
them uh to get through at least you know
the the week
and you know like I you know it's
reasonable most guys are not going to
want to spend $20,000 that's just for
the suit we're not talking about dress
shirt top
uh shoes so just for the suits you're
spending $20,000 and you know most guys
don't want to do that so good yeah I
think that yeah it makes perfect sense
but it's just it's also amusing how much
we try to Proclaim that what you wear
doesn't matter that much and then when
it bugs us especially if you're on the
opposite side of some controversy
suddenly it matters a lot to people uh I
think it's it's very telling right okay
let's that that was great thank you so
much but I want to switch maybe to a
little more practical vein here because
you're very good at giving out advice uh
and and judgments because not only do
you say this is you know thumbs up
thumbs down but you give reasons why so
I thought that maybe we could help the
listeners uh that you know there's both
men and women out there listening so
we'll try to be as general as possible
but let's imagine the median mindscape
listener is like a graduate student in
physics or something like that or you
know the equivalent kind of middle of
the road in terms of income and social
station do you think that H how
important is it for someone like that to
have a personal style to you know kind
of be coherent in how you dress no
matter how what that style might
be are we talking about in personal life
or for in the classroom for academic P
purposes or I guess not even in the
classroom but just you know there's I
guess a professional wardrobe but also a
a casual everyday wardrobe I guess what
I'm asking is would would you would you
try to persuade people that they should
be thoughtful about what they wear and
and try to have some version of a
style I think of it it's just whether
you take joy in it I think it's fine if
you don't if you don't have any interest
in clothes I think that's totally fine
if you don't particularly like if you
don't enjoy dressing well I think it's
fine it's it's just to me it's just a
hobby it's like um you know should
somebody drive I don't know nicer car or
eat nicer food or whatever it is do you
do you enjoy a friend of mine I just had
a dinner over at him and his wife's
house the other day um he's an academic
he you know graduated uh with a PhD in
biophysics he has no interest in clothes
it is he it's
like he complained to me because I re
recomended him um a custom dress shirt
that cost him 200 bucks and it wore out
after 5 years and he complained that
took you know wore out after 5 years and
I was like that's that's five years five
years um meanwhile he loves he's you
know he loves food so he'll spend $150
on a dinner and to him that's where his
enjoyment lies I will say that um for
professional
purposes there is sometimes for certain
people um an advance Vantage to dressing
in a way to distinguish yourself from
students that may be if you're a younger
uh Professor um maybe if you're a
graduate student you want to dress
differently than your undergrads it may
be that you're a woman or a person of
color and you want to establish yourself
as um an authority in your field right
um but these things sometimes vary by
field as well in the hard Sciences it
may be very normal for a guy to show up
in
you know like cargo shorts and a polo
shirt or something he may even look more
intelligent because he conforms to this
notion of what a absent-minded scientist
May wear something whereas someone in
let's say ethnic studies or something or
English has to dress in you know maybe a
tailor jacket because they want people
to take their field more seriously quote
unquote um so it varies by field I think
uh it varies who you are and what
challenges you want to overcome but I do
think that there may be advantages to
paying at least some attention to your
dress when you go into a classroom
because it can
help in some ways establish your
bonafides even if even if it shouldn't
right people should be paying attention
to quality of your work but the reality
is that when you get in front of a
classroom sometimes people don't take
you as seriously if you dress a certain
way um but that's going to be very
contextual the school the location of
the school the city your field you know
you as a person
um it it I would say when you're talking
about like a very general person it
would even though I often criticize it
on Twitter I think it's kind of a boring
aesthetic uh but it'd be hard to go
wrong with like a pair of like flat
front chinos you know like a collge
shirt of some sort and you know a
sweater when it's cold um
you know like just like the Bare Basics
of like I mean not that I believe in
like respective respectability of dress
but there's a language out there for the
respectability of dress and sometimes
you can use that language to your
advantage you know I do tell sometimes
tell my students graduate students um
when they seem reluctant to speak up in
uh conferences or talks or whatever and
I and I say like you know it's good for
you it's good for you you trying to
become a scientist or whatever and you
know you have to participate in the
discourse and of course their answer is
but I don't want to be judged right I
don't want people to judge me harshly
and right I would like to say oh don't
worry you're not being judged but the
only thing I can honestly say is well
yes you are being judged all the time
whether you like it or not and that's
Pro I don't even think about it but it's
probably true for the clothing too
right I yeah I agree yeah even if you
opt out you're still being judged that's
just the
reality again I I don't think that we as
individuals should judge others but it's
undeniable that other people will judge
us so you should I think move through
life you can choose not to but even if
you choose not to people will still look
at you and they'll make an impression
you know they'll if you wear certain
things they'll form a certain idea about
you um again it's it's just very
difficult to go wrong with like you know
just like Chinos if you can afford them
I think if you're a graduate student it
might be tough because wool trousers can
be kind of expensive and they'll wear
down a little bit faster than chinos uh
but if you afford them you know wool
trousers can be very nice
um yeah these
are I mean you know there's not like a
secret to it right it's uh that that
aesthetic is like J crew yeah kind of
like you like everyone knows what it is
so it's not
I do think that it's not of it's not
always the most like stylish it's you
know like they are more interesting and
like fulfilling ways to dress but if you
just want to look respectable in the
classroom like yeah just go to J crew
and buy some things well you touched on
an issue which I'm sure is in the back
of some people's minds which is that
sometimes this costs money and we have
to take that into consideration what do
you tell people who say to you this
whole clothes as a hobby thing sounds
great but isn't it an awfully pricey
hobby to dress really
well yes it's true good if you if you
take it if you take it as a hobby it's
going to be expensive
however if you if your goal is to just
dress well then no you can do it very
inexpensively um if if if you make it
your hobby and if you're just like
really interestes in clothes yeah it's
going to be expensive but if you're just
trying to dress well you can get um you
can get chinos there's a company online
called spe McKay it's called it's
spelled SP p i e r and then the word and
and then m a c k a y okay uh the
downside to them is that you are
shopping online which means that you are
going to know want to do three things uh
one is you're going to want to check the
return policy um and for them they give
you free returns on the first order so
you know like keep that in mind um two
you're probably going to want to buy two
sizes if you're interested in something
if you're starting out you you know
sometimes having two sizes gives you
some options at home to figure out what
fits you best and three the most
important thing is you you want to start
measuring clothes at home that fit you
well so if you have a sweater that fits
you really well you lay it flat on a
table or your bed and you measure it
from armpit to armpit on the front turn
the Garment over then you measure from
shoulder seam to shoulder seam on at the
back and then again on the back you
measure from the bottom of the collar
down to the Hem down the center back
this gives you chest shoulder and length
measurements use those three if you if
you often have problems with sleeves
then you will want to measure um the
center of the back collar seam down to
the sleeve cuff but with certain things
like sweaters you can always fold the
cuff back with dress shirts you can take
it to the tailor but the first three are
very important
because chest shoulder and length are
much harder to alter at the alterations
tailor okay so you want to know those
measurements and then you can buy things
at places like spear McKay um and
they're really affordable you get like
pair of pants for 60 bucks um you know
you buy like three of them right that'll
cover you cover you for at least a week
um you can rotate yeah and you know buy
a few dress shirts for when you need to
do a presentation um and if you can
afford to you can buy a tailor jacket
usually sport coat that the one that
is fail safe is a Navy sport coat in a
textured fabric like hopsack or Surge
and uh if you you know if you're going
to an academic conference you put on a
sport coat it just makes you look a lot
better yeah
um you know you don't have to go the
full suit you don't have to go full tie
but having Chino's a dress shirt and a
sport coat allows you to break up those
things to look um quote unquote nice at
different formality levels so you don't
always have to wear the sport coat but
if you buy a suit for example that
suit's going to be a suit right some
suits can be broken into separates
there's like a whole language to that of
like which can and which can't but when
you're just starting out you're probably
not going to need a suit you can
probably just get away with a sport coat
and then at that point by by you know
breaking up those pieces you can dress
aoly for different
situations um and yeah you know Spirit
McKay sport coats I think are like 300
bucks um you know it's not cheap but you
know you're not looking at uh you know
like thousands of dollars um and these
are things that you can wear if
you you know like unless your body
changes dramatic shape these are things
you can wear for like 10 15 sometimes 20
years um well sport Cod anyway the pants
will not last that long but um the pants
should last you you know like a good
five seven
years yeah so we're I always like to
think of these things as rates right
like how much are you wearing how much
are you spending not to buy the thing
but per time you will use it so we're
talking you know a few bucks for a sport
code like
that yeah I agree if you if you're you
know cost per wear goes down when you
when you think of it over the time
period that you're wearing them um
and I I think there is I would just
caution there are ways to get clothes
for cheaper for example like shopping on
eBay I would just be careful with things
like tailor jackets because tailoring is
so particular in terms of fit that
unless you've tried that model on before
you're often taking a gamble um but if
you have tried on a model and you know
it works for you then you can look up
that model on eBay and find it for Less
um if you
if you if you want to dress down the
chinos you can always get like a you
know dark pair of jeans there's a
company called Gustin
GN they sell uh dark kind of raw denim
jeans for I want to say like maybe 60 or
70 bucks um and those will last you I
mean even with regular wear they should
last you like five six years um so you
know and those will be jeans that
depending on the model you don't you
don't want to wear like overly skinny
low-rise jeans with a sport coat um so
depending on the model that's something
that you may be able to wear with a
sport coat and then obviously you can
wear
casually and this brings us to another
thing that is very important that you
you've mentioned a couple times the idea
of the tailoring I I've noticed that for
people who don't think about clothes
very much when they do they think about
the color the fabric the design but
people who think about clothes a lot are
think about the fit all the time like
does this thing actually fit you or not
so so that's a way to level up the
clothes you wear is to really make sure
that they fit you correctly whatever
that might
take yeah I agree I mean you can have um
10 you know 10 Navy sport codes and they
can look totally different depending on
the cut in the
construction you know without since
we're speaking over a podcast it's hard
to give visuals but um the easy way to I
think the three easiest ways if you're
if you're talking about sport coats and
suit suit jackets the three things to
look for is when you're putting on the
jacket see if the collar which is the
part of the jacket that hugs the touches
your neck make sure that collar stays on
your neck even when you're moving around
again within reason like you know if
you're if you're swimming if you're
moving your arms like you're swimming
through a swimming pool it's not going
to stay on your neck um unless you're
going bespoke but you know like if
you're kind of like Reaching Forward for
things and stuff the the collar should
stay on your neck um the other thing to
look for is a jacket that's long enough
to at least cover your bum and that is a
big problem with a lot of red wear
because Trends have just pushed the
jacket shorter and shorter um make sure
that the jacket at least covers your
rear uh an even better measure is that
when you're looking at yourself in the
mirror while you're wearing the jacket
the jacket should end about halfway from
the jacket collar to the floor when
you're wearing heeled shoes but at the
very least it should cover your bum the
third thing this is the easi thing is
when you when you fasten the jacket when
you button the jacket
um look to see if the the lapels are
buckling away from your chest look to
see if the sleeve head has a divot look
to see if there's pulling across across
the uh waist all of these are
indications that the jacket doesn't fit
you if if the if the shoulders have a
divot if the sleeve has a divot if the
chest the lapels are buckling from your
chest that means likely that the chest
is too small for you if the uh when you
fasten it across the waist if the waist
is pulling that means the waist is too
small for you the jacket should fit
cleanly but still have a nice silhouette
um but what has happened over the years
that many many guys particularly buy
these really small jackets and one it
doesn't give them you know like you're
going to gain weight over the course of
10 years and if you buy a jacket that
doesn't even allow you to eat a bowl of
spaghetti it's not going to it's not
even going to last a year let alone 10
years but um many guys buy these really
small jackets and it just it's
constricting and it it doesn't flatter
them very well so when you put it on
just see to make sure it lays cleanly um
has a nice silhouette it's not puckering
or pulling anywhere and those puckering
those pulls those are the indications
that something doesn't fit on you you
may in those cases either want to size
up or when you size up and it doesn't
just still doesn't look good on you you
just move to a different model at some
point you have to like try on many
different models to figure out your own
fit challenges and um everybody has
their own particular set of fit
challenges and they end up having to
figure out ways to overcome that either
through ready to wear or Custom
Tailoring or ready to wear that's been
altered through you know an alterations
tailor so and so forth well you
mentioned just now ready to wear Custom
Tailoring we we've we've mentioned
bespoke let's lay out what all these
terms mean for the person out there like
what are the levels of category that we
can get into if we're going to buy a
suit for
ourselves so bespoke uh I mean to go
through the very corny kind
of categorization of it bespoke comes
from when you used to go to a tailor and
a piece of cloth was spoken for somebody
had already spoken for that cloth and
they're going to make it into a garment
but smoke is really just how clothes
clothes were made before the Advent of
rid wear so uh you know before the
middle of the 19th century or so
everyone with the exception of slaves
and uh laborers wore custom clothes if
you wanted to get clothes you'd go to
the tailor you'd have them made or
someone would make it for you in the
home so the practices of bespoke vary to
some degree because it's just how
clothes were made before the invention
of rated wear rated wear is very obvious
it's just stuff that you go to the store
it's already made a designer came up
with the idea a pattern maker figured
out what are the proportions of their
Target demographic and then they made
this item and then you go on and you try
it on and see if it works on
you ready made is like very standard and
very obvious made to measure is
somewhere between these two worlds okay
where made to measure is means that
somebody came up with a block pattern
which is like a like an architectural
draft of how a garment should fit they
came up with this block pattern
and you go to a store you get measured
and then they end up adjusting the block
pattern to fit you and then uh after
they've adjusted the block pattern
they'll make the Garment straight to
finish they'll deliver it to the store
you try it on and any adjustments from
there are basically what would happen um
if you just brought a ready ready to
wear garment to the store and had it
altered the problem with made to measure
is that its success depends on how far
you you are from the Block
so to give an example if the block is
made for a very slim person and you have
a bit of a
belly they can extend the the what the
tailor is called the front balance a
little bit to cover you know your gut
but they can only extend it so much
before other proportions get thrown off
and they have to draft a new
pattern in an Ideal World you go to a
made to measure shop and they will tell
you this is not going to work for you
but we don't live in an Ideal World
people are just trying often just trying
to make money salespeople may not be
experienced so you may go in and they
just measure you they adjust the block
and even through that adjustment doesn't
fit you all of a sudden now you have a
garment that is not salvageable even
through
alterations that's the danger of a lot
of made to measure um is that the block
was not thoughtfully constructed it's
often amalgamation of Trends or that
you're too far off from the Block
bespoke sometimes uses a block pattern
even on Salo many tailor now are using
block patterns to streamline the process
but theoretically they should draft a
completely new pattern to ensure the
best fit and not only is the pattern
made for you but um the Garment is made
through an iterative stages of two to
three sometimes even four fittings so
the Garment uh you know they'll draft
the pattern they'll base some you know
the pieces together you come in they fit
it on you and they figure out uh does it
look right how do you feel and then
they'll adjust it they'll bring it back
to the workroom you know fiddle with it
you come back for another fitting so and
so forth until the Garment is correct
the the problem with the Custom
Tailoring processes is that just because
it's custom doesn't mean it's good you
could have a bad tailor um you could
have chosen an ugly fabric you could
have chosen bad TAA Tails they're all
all sorts of ways a custom garment can
be bad which is why I always tell people
start with rated wear first figure out
what are your own fit challenges figure
out what you like what kind of you know
silhouette you like whether things work
for you off the rack because if things
don't work for you off the rack you can
always just put it back on the rack
there's there's right there's no cost
whereas if you go to a Custom Tailor
doesn't work out you've just lost a
th000 to 4,000 sometimes even $10,000
depending on where you go so um start
with rated wear figure out your own fit
challenges and then um if you if you
know you're a certain size if you're
John Federman you need to go B spoke but
most people are not that size um so just
figure out what what level is right for
you do you personally have favorite
kinds of suits in ter I mean there's
like very conservative IBM executive
blue and black suits but then you can
get pretty wild out there right there's
the double breasted and 3 piece and
there seems to be a lot of variety even
a in a relatively restrictive fashion
category yeah I you know suits used to
be the uniform of business dress and
that is no longer true for most
Industries except for you know sometimes
law finance and newscasters and suit
salesmen um so I think everyone should
have at least one what I call a serious
suit which is a conservative suit single
breasted uh Notch lapel uh made from a
dark worsted cloth in a sober color like
gray or navy and you need to have this
suit because this is the thing that
you're going to wear to weddings
funerals Court appearances Christian
thingss all of the stuff that calls for
a suit and sometimes these events come
up
unexpectedly you don't plan for to
attend someone's funeral right like it
happens and then you need a suit and
often I'll get emails from people saying
I need to get a suit next week where do
I go and the answer is you're you're
screwed because you should have been
doing that way in advance now you're
going to spend five six 700 on something
that quite honestly is not going to look
very good and then hopefully you'll find
something that looks good later um so
find one serious suit for when you need
it because those times are going to
come after that most people do not need
another serious suit because most people
don't wear suits to work so um for the
academic that wants to go to conferences
and you know might want something for
certain kind of professional settings I
think it would be good to get a sport
coat um but if you are interested in
suits and you want to wear
suits then yeah I this is a difficult
thing because suits are expensive but I
really do think that the second third
suit should be a fun garment that you
enjoy wearing um in the springtime it
can be cotton or Linen in the summer
months it can be sear sucker if if the
kind of like if sear sucker sounds too
like Southern mint julip swilling cigar
chomping Trad then you can go for tonal
Navy sear sucker so like Sears sucker is
traditionally blue uh blue stripes on a
white cloth whereas a tonal Navy sear
sucker is basically all blue and you
just get the texture um that can be very
nice
in the summer time in the winter time it
can be corduroy um certain types of
Tweeds it can be Calvary twill I really
like mohare wool Blends for evening um
because mohare wool blend has a certain
Sheen that I think looks really nice
under artificial light
and I think we we live in a time where
again as I was saying there are very few
consequences to dress at this point so I
think you can just wear a suit because
you enjoy wearing a suit like yeah some
people are going to ask like why are you
so dressed up but like nothing's going
to happen to you right like they're not
going to put you in jail so um if that
brings you Joy if you enjoy doing that
then I think that's something that you
can if you want you can wear that you
know you can wear a kind of semi-casual
suit to you know professional settings
but many people will find it much easier
to wear that for example to a nice
restaurant or to the theater um even if
no one else at the restaurant is wearing
tailored clothing especially if a friend
of mine dresses up for for to go out
with his wife every Friday and his rule
is is that if there's white tablecloth
at the restaurant he feels it's
appropriate for tailor clothing and I
think that's a pretty good rule but even
if there's not white tablecloth for me
um I I live in the Bay area so I just
think like if the place is serving like
$25 plates of spaghetti I'm going to
wear tailored clothing uh um because for
me that's like you know that's like a
nice night out uh once you factor in
drinks and all that's like 50 bucks so I
think you can you can do that and it can
just be an enjoyable night out it is a
little bit easier if you can find
friends who also like dressing up right
um
so not that you should only invite women
but you know I I found that
women are happy to take the opportunity
for a night to just dress up to have fun
to go out to eat um but there are also
men that also enjoy these things so you
find a group you say maybe we do it once
a week or we do it once a month we go
out to a nice restaurant um it's just to
some degree for me anyway 50 bucks for a
meal a meal and two drinks to me that's
expensive I don't know other people's
budgets but um it's an for me it's an
expensive meal but it's a cheap way to
have a nice night and to unwind um
compared to the other ways that one can
spend money um and yeah it just becomes
a fun thing to dress up go out relax and
have a nice night um but again if if
someone is just building a a new
wardrobe I would say you need that one
serious suit for those weddings funerals
you know those kind of occasions and
then you should probably get for
academic listeners you should probably
get a sport coat maybe even two sport
coats um for when you need them um and
those those I think flatter your frame
more than casual Weare um and will still
look appropriate in a classroom but if
you're the kind of person that really
enjoys wearing tail clothing that and
make that second suit like you know a a
mohir wool blend or a linen or something
that you can wear out for social
occasions and it will just be a fun
thing um and nowadays spear McKay suits
for example
are I want to say like 400 bucks so not
inexpensive but you know it's probably
not going to make a huge difference in
your tax bracket
um it's a you know it's something that
you can buy and wear for many years and
especially now we're looking at the
holidays it's something you wear for
holiday parties um and it's just
something to you know kind of spruce up
life well I actually really appreciate
that little digression because I do
think that there's a whole bunch of
people who probably think of dressing up
as a Duty or a chore and you're saying
that that you know implicitly you should
take joy in it which is almost always
good advice uh I actually was at an
event just last week when I I had to fly
somewhere and I had to you know dress
nicely in a suit in fact and I didn't
have time to change before coming back
on the airplane and I got to say that
you know I kind of felt like I was
looking good for traveling on an
airplane where usually I dress like a
slob but you can actually no matter what
your everyday wardrobe is get some
pleasure out of that if you take the
right attitude toward
it yeah I I think of it just as a
private pleasure it's just it's just
really nice it feels good to wear
something that makes you feel cool and
and and great you know I mean just it's
a very basic thing and that's how I feel
again you you know no one has to take
interest in it but if you do it's it's
really enjoyable um if Taylor clothing
feels too formal for your lifestyle you
can you can do that in other ways you
know you can do that depending on your
vocation depending on your environment
your age you can do that with Field
Jackets trucker jackets um if you're an
academic you might be able to do you
know like the barber jacket kind of
thing um I think that still looks fairly
at home in on many campuses um whatever
that garment is for you you can find it
and it will feel good um it can just be
a way
to have some you know a routine that you
enjoy in the morning and you'll walk
around and
I mean not to sound vain but you know
you'll like how you look in the
reflection when you pass by store
Windows that's all um yeah there there
are worse things to be into so did you
ever see a TV show called Instinct uh
starring Ellen
Coming no this is from just a few years
ago but Ellen plays a university
Professor actually who it's a police
procedural so he's Consulting for the
police but his character on that show
was in my opinion the best dress person
I've ever seen on TV and what what
really struck me was not only did he
wear nice suits but he would have these
Exquisite color and pattern combinations
and I have no idea how it was done
obviously it was not alen cumming's
choice there's people who are dressing
him but am I wrong to think that that's
probably another level of intimidation
that people go through if they're not
used to doing this a fear of either
being too matchy and just wearing the
same color and looking like like you're
at the senior prom or having clashing
colors or something like that is this
something that can be learned or you
just have the instinct or you
don't no you absolutely it's a it's a
skill like anything else you learn it
and it's absolutely true that in the
beginning you know you'll probably
probably you know do some things wrong
but you end up learning and it's
enjoyable along the way I mean um as you
know you know with students you
encourage them to speak up and um and
engage in discourse it's you know with
any skill you just you practice and you
get better at it um the only only thing
I would say is that
there's have you heard of the spotlight
effect I've mentioned this a few times
on Twitter right yeah I have go ahead
but explain it to people so so the
spotlight effect was a famous um
psychology study where they told a group
of undergrads to partici you know
undergrads would get paid or I think
they got you know they're supposed to
get paid to to to arrive at some
classroom for some study and they told
everybody to arrive at a certain
classroom except for one person who they
gave the wrong location and when this
person arrived at the wrong location
they said oh you know the the location
was changed at the last minute uh you
have to rush over to this new location
but before you go you have to put on
this uh t-shirt and the T-shirt had a
big print of Barry manalo's face and in
in the academic paper the authors made a
big point to say that Barry Manalo was
considered very uncool at the time which
I thought is a hilarious insult to Barry
Manalo um so the student puts on this
Barry Manalo t-shirt runs you know
across across the hall or down you know
different buildings gets gets to the
classroom and opens the door and the
person the the classroom has been
arranged so that all the other students
who who had already arrived are facing
this person who has just opened the door
and so imagine being the student you
open the door you see all these students
looking at you you go try to find a seat
you're shuffling around then you know
you've already embarrassed you're making
this noise you sit down you unzip your
backpack and then soon after the person
in the class that's leading the study
says oh you know I think you've arried
too late uh unfortunately you're going
to have to leave and uh you know you
we'll we'll try to compensate you in
some other way so then you got to like
pick up your stuff leave it's like a
horrifying experience finally get it out
of the classroom you know you probably
feel like crap and then all of a sudden
there's another uh investigator outside
the classroom who says I'd like to ask
you some questions and they ask you you
know how you're feeling at the time so
and so forth and one of the questions
was how many people in there do you
think noticed your Berry Manalo
t-shirt and they would also ask the
students in the classroom how many of
you can say what that person was wearing
and by a huge margin the person outside
overestimated the number of people
inside the classroom that noticed what
they're wearing and so the term
Spotlight effect was our tendency
to to to think essentially kind of like
the main character effect we think we
are the main characters of our world and
our emotional state when we are feeling
flustered anxious um we're feeling
nervous we use these feelings as anchors
to interpret other people's readings of
us
and I think this happens often when you
are wearing something new especially if
you're new to dressing you may be used
to wearing whatever it is you know
shorts or jeans or whatever and t-shirts
and then all of a sudden you're wearing
something nicer and you know you might
feel a little self-conscious about it
yeah and you go to work and you know
you're already feeling self
self-conscious and someone says oh you
you look very dressed up today and your
feeling of being feeling self-conscious
is then as an serves as an anchor where
you think oh people think I look stupid
or they think I'm trying too hard or
they're noticing me and all these things
you know I had dinner with um a fashion
designer a couple months ago um who's a
woman and who grew up in the South
and I was surprised that this is also
true for women like like dressing up in
this like casual town she had she had
noticed noted that her mom had felt this
at certain social situations um you know
when when you are dressed more formally
or fancier or whatever it is or even
differently from others you may feel
self-conscious so then when someone
comments on your tire even if they're
complimenting you they're saying
something nice about how you look you
feel
uncomfortable um and I think that just
takes some practice it's about you it's
about your own self-conscious ious so
after a while you're so used to wearing
these clothes they're just your clothes
you're not self-conscious and when
someone compliments you it may make your
day you may feel good um or it just even
if you know it just may not bother you
um I think when when clothing becomes
just like a part of your
daily uh routine and it's a private
pleasure that's when I think it's the
most fulfilling and again yes everyone
stumbles along the way with any skill
that they pick up not just dressing um
but it's just kind of rolling with it
and enjoying it like with any hobby if
you were I don't know building trains
you're probably going to build a ugly
train the first train that you build but
eventually you're going to build some
beautiful trains um and it's just an
enjoyable thing to to do over the course
of your life and um it will always be
that at the end like people are going to
look at you and think oh that person
just wear clothes well and I I can never
dress like that um that's where it
always always ends up
so well I I did want to give you a
little bit of a chance you because You'
mentioned that your own personal
expertise is in men's clothing but but
you've mentioned women have slightly
different challenges it seems to me that
most of what you've said would apply to
women's clothing just as well as men but
maybe there's some additional challenges
that women have that men don't have to
face yeah I definitely think that there
are many unique challenges I mean I I I
don't comment on women's clothing online
because it's not my area there are
people who know much more about it than
me to me it's sort of like asking
someone who studes English to comment on
Chinese or something they're just
different languages so I don't
know I mean if you ask for one I'm I'm
not a woman I don't buy women's clothing
so someone who buys women's clothing is
going to know like oh this was you know
this flatters or this doesn't FL this
signals this and this signals that those
are not signals that I know because I
don't pay attention to this language
right um but certainly they face many
unique challenges I'm thinking of a New
York Times article that was written I
want to say about 10 years ago it came
up with um uh sexual harassment case at
UC Berkeley where a graduate student
brought a sexual harassment case against
her
adviser and she was called to testify on
it uh in front of a board and she had to
think how to put together an outfit that
was convincing that she would be the
person that would be sexually harassed
but also was uh a
reliable voice I mean there are all
these like crazy considerations I mean
some if some if someone kind of just
Googles the article they'll find it it's
like this long list of considerations I
have never had to consider um and I mean
that's obviously a uh you know a
specific case but you know I mean just
women face unique challenges than men
and therefore their clothes you know are
intersect with that and I think that's
true for you know everybody everyone has
like their own kind of unique
circumstances um so that's partly the
reason why I don't comment on women's we
because I don't have that background or
experience and uh it's to me it's just a
different language yeah that that is
that is perfectly fair so for the last
question then I wanted to bring up
another Twitter controversy this was an
extremely minor one but someone posted a
picture
of uh someone wearing what looked to me
like a perfectly good tie and a
perfectly good knot and you uh disagreed
that this was a good tie I think this is
the first time that you've given advice
that like hit me where it hurt I'm like
oh no I'm that guy dressing badly
according to Derek uh and you argued for
a slightly asew tie knot and the the
justification was that we should look
really good but not like we're trying
too hard to look good and I don't even
know if you realize but this was quote
tweeted by some philosophers and they
got into an argument about whether or
not that is a good way to go through
life looking like we don't try too much
I mean say more about why our ties
should be just slightly
asymmetrical so there are many there are
many ways again you know I think of
there are many ways to think of
Aesthetics
so
um
so a sociological view so we're talking
a foreign hand is what you're referring
to a foreign hand is a slightly
asymmetrical knot where one side of the
knot is straighter than the other side
and this is different from the more
popular Half Windsor or full Windsor
even um where the two sides of the knot
are
symmetrical
um I'm going to say something that I
think is just a sociological observation
I'm not making a
um it's not it's not my own personal uh
value judgment but I'm just making
sociological
observation there the foreign hand
conforms to Notions again of capital g
capital t good taste because it was
often the KN used by people who went
through private schools and had to wear
a certain uniform and often used by
people who
were like in Elite Class essentially so
the foreign hand was just considered
more of a quote unquote good taste knot
again in in a sociological sense um and
that's why it's often favored by people
who are obsessed with good taste
um the other thing in terms of like how
it looks is that I think the foreign
hand is better because it's it's a
smaller knot dep it depends the size of
the knot depends on the top how the tie
was cut interlining that was used inside
and the shell fabric these are all kind
of like elements that play but generally
speaking the same tie will look thick
the same tie will tie a thicker knot if
you use a Half Windsor or full Windsor
than a foreign hand because you're
wrapping it the way you wrap the the
knot together and I think a smaller knot
looks better because it just becomes
less of like this big thing under your
chin that's the other thing but there's
also this idea
of a slightly aew knot conveys in my
opinion also this kind
of this kind of casual nonchalant
naturalness to it where things don't
look perfect it's sort of the same
reason why if you're still if you and I
wear pocket squares it's not a value
judment but if you're if you're one of
those guys that still wears a pocket
square to me it looks better if you just
stuff it in rather than if you like go
through these like origami like folds
and you always I think you always look
best if the outfit looks like this is
just how you happen to look versus I put
a ton of effort into this thing partly
because it looks a little bit more
natural and then I think naturalness
looks good it's sort of like the same
with skateboarding or whatever it is any
skill that you exhibit when it looks a
little bit more natural it's impressive
um and then also in dress it suggests to
the viewer that I could look better if I
put in more effort but this is just my
disheveled look like this is just like
me throwing stuff together
and um when you look at kind of like
really well-dressed men in the past they
often exhibit this kind of character
where the clothes highlight the person
and it doesn't you don't end up being
just the thing that lifts the clothes
through the room you the clothes don't
speak louder than you the clothes
support you as a person you end up just
looking as natural and comfortable as
can be um and I think the slightly a
skew not the the you know kind of like
stuffed in pocket square if you're still
the kind of guy that wears pocket
squares um if the tailoring is beautiful
and that that to me is where all the
effort comes at the front you learn what
colors go together what textures go
together what Fabrics go together you
figure out what fits you figure out what
Silhouettes look beautiful if you happen
to use custom tails you go to good
Custom Tailor not bad Custom Tailor you
do all the work up front and
then in the morning you just throw stuff
on and when you kind of like meet very
beautifully dressed people in my view it
just looks so natural it just is like
they threw something on they didn't
think too hard about it and it just
looks beautiful in that sense versus
when everything is so perfect it almost
gives up the game
um yeah it just doesn't it doesn't come
off the same way to me but go ahead it's
to me it's it's a minor thing it's a
minor thing if if someone wants to wear
a Half Windsor you know if you're
wearing beautiful tailoring it's
beautiful tailoring whether you wear
Half Windsor for not that's a such a
trivial small detail I would never say
that someone's badly dressed because
they're wearing a Half Windsor well I
think you've changed my life here uh I I
love the philosophy of the
slightly imperfect nonchalant that's
something we can all aim for so Derek I
thanks so much for being on the mscate
podcast thanks so much for having
me
[Music]
w